[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory
which of hogwarts founders lived the
most tragic life you might be tempted to
answer with salazar slytherin
but if we take a second look at the four
co-founders we'll find that rowena
ravenclaw might have suffered the
greatest tragedy of all
what was it and why was it so awful join
us and find out as we take a look at the
life and times of rowena ravenclaw
birth and early life
rowena ravenclaw just like her other
co-founders of hogwarts represented a
unique part of the british landscape
while godric gryffindor is from a small
town in the west country of england
helga hufflepuff lived in a rural
hill-covered county in wales and salazar
southern was reported to have been born
in ireland helga represented scotland
and called the highlands her home all
four of them were born in the 10th
century some decades before they founded
hogwarts sometime around 990 a.d
in the years leading to the formation of
the school rowena had already become
renowned as one of the most skilled
witches of her era
her mastery of charms which she would
later use to create her famous diadem
made her quite a formidable magic user
her thirst for knowledge pushed her to
study magic at a pace nearly no other
wizard or witch could compete with
but it wasn't just her tenacity that
made her a powerful witch
rowena also possessed an inexplicable
innate connection to the magical world
which is best reflected in her dreams
price meeting her co-founders rowena
would often dream of a wild boar
in those dreams the beast would wind
through the woods and valleys until it
drew her to the foot of a massive dark
blue lake
later in life rowena took these dreams
as a premonition and used them to guide
her when choosing hogwarts location
right at the foot of the great lake
which many grindelows called home
founding hogwarts by the year 990 a.d
rowena had known her fellow hogwarts
founders for some time
although helga hufflepuff was her
closest friend in the bunch the other
two members godric gryffindor and
salazar slytherin were important to her
as well together they created a hogwarts
school of witchcraft and wizardry
and dedicated their lives to educating
the magical youth of britain in the ways
of the wizarding world
although the ministry of magic was still
a few centuries away from creation the
ancient britain that rowena called home
was still ruled by a complex series of
laws
with disputes between muggles and
wizards always increasing rowena and her
fellow teachers strived to keep their
students safe and for a relatively short
while they achieved just that
as one of the co-founders of hogwarts
rowena left a strong impression on the
school
in the years that followed her death the
value she instilled continued making
house ravenclaw every bit as formidable
as it had been during rowena's tenure
when choosing students rowena had a very
specific set of qualities that she
looked for
unlike godric gryffindor who sought
courage or slytherin who went after
purebloods ravenclaw wanted only the
brightest students the entire wizarding
world would come to know just how
selective ravenclaw was
and the graduates from a house would
show off their affiliation with great
honor
daughter
at some point during her time as a
professor at hogwarts rowena's daughter
enrolled at the school we're not quite
sure what rowan's relationship with the
young girl was like but it's easy to see
that something was wrong
although the historical records never
mention it a second look at rowena's
life and achievements might tell us all
we need to know about her merit as a
parent
rowena was ambitious ambitious enough to
devote her time and energy to the
arduous task of creating hogwarts
she likely worked tirelessly at this
task while helena was still a young
child
something that could have built
animosity between the two and whether
rowena deliberately sought to burden her
or not the pressure of having one of the
smartest witches in britain as your
mother was second to none
helena likely bought a weight of
perfection and studied tirelessly to
live up to her mother's expectations
after all by the time helena enrolled in
hogwarts she would need to be smart
enough for her mother to accept her into
her own house ravenclaw
all this pressure combined with the
judgment of her peers in the wizarding
community drove helena to resent her
mother even more
and when helena finally acted out the
harm was too much for her mother rowena
to bear
sorting hat and slytherin's departure
but before we move to the final conflict
between rohingya and her daughter helena
let's look back at rowena's time at
hogwarts because she was involved in
some pretty important milestones
after a few years when hogwarts had
developed a reputation as the premier
destination for britain's wizarding
youth the founders turned their
attention toward their legacy
how could hogwarts continue forward
after the four of them had died
eventually a system of headmasters would
evolve in order to run the
administrative side of the school
but in terms of the spirit of the houses
and keeping the flame of the original
four founders alive rowena and her peers
decided to create a device to sort
students into the correct houses
each considered the individual character
of their students as the most important
part of the selection process so they
took godric's old hat and enchanted it
from that moment it became known as the
sorting hat and it decided which house
firsties would join after they took the
journey across the great lake
some time later slytherin's concern for
the legacy of the school drove a wedge
between him and the other founders
salazar was increasingly worried that
mudbloods would ruin hogwarts and wanted
to bar their enrollment
but rowena along with helga and godric
wouldn't even entertain the idea
in the end slytherin was forced to leave
while rowena and the other two founders
remained
helena's betrayal and murder
but it wouldn't be long before rowena
met her own demise
while her daughter helena was still a
student at hogwarts she decided to run
away
the animosity between her and her mother
had grown too great
overwhelmed by the adoration her mother
drew from other wizards and witches
helena vowed that she would become even
greater
so she stole her mother's enchanted
diadem and took off for albania
her mother's diadem was supposedly
bewitched so that it granted its wearer
greater wisdom
but in the months that followed helena's
act of betrayal she never seemed to grow
any wiser
back at hogwarts rowena could hardly
fathom what had happened instead of
telling her fellow founders and
enlisting the help to bring helena back
to safety rowena hid the entire ordeal
although godric and salazar might not
have been helpful romina wrongly hid the
ordeal from helga hufflepuff
helga more than any witch in the
wizarding world was renowned for her
compassion and her ability to reach out
to troubled magic users but in the end
the shame was simply too much for rowena
to bear
soon after helena's departure rowena
fell ill
although she didn't know it at the time
she was dying
magical historians often wonder if
rowena died from a heartache due to her
daughter's disappearance
such a fate wasn't uncommon in the
ancient magical world
unfortunately we might never know the
truth
but in those final days rowena made
another grave mistake
realizing that her end was drawing near
rowena wanted nothing more than to see
her dear daughter again
even though helen had stolen her
treasured item rowena was eager to
forgive her and hoped to hold her hand
as she passed but instead of calling
upon her fellow co-founders for aid
rowena turned to a strange ally the
bloody baron
known then only as the baron he was a
strange boy he was one of salazar
slytherin's earliest students and he was
consumed with many of the same vices
that other dark wizards possessed but
mostly his hot temper often led him to
trouble and ultimately would be the
cause of helena's death
rowena turned to the baron for a simple
reason he was obsessed with her daughter
since their time as students at hogwarts
the baron had tried to make helena his
spouse but she always refused
rowena still as sharp as ever knew that
the baron was the one person she could
send to albania who wouldn't just quit
when the pursuit became too difficult
but rowena underestimated just how
rageful the baron was when he finally
located helena in albania he once again
tried to confess his love
but this time when helena rejected him
the baron withdrew a razor sharp dagger
and struck her dead
in the end rowena probably died before
her daughter ever returned as a ghost
legacy
when we look at rowena ravenclaw's
legacy and all that she accomplished
it's hard not to ignore her personal
failings she created one of the most
disciplined houses at any wizarding
school
and as we've already mentioned
she actually chose the iconic location
for hogwarts construction
a decision that led to innumerable
famous encounters between students and
magical creatures within the great lake
and forbidden forest according to legend
rowena even designed the shifting floor
plan which made hogwarts almost
unchartable unless you had the marauders
map of course
for all these accomplishments and more
rowena ravenclaw is easily one of the
most interesting co-founders at hogwarts
but perhaps the only way to achieve
these great deeds was to sacrifice her
relationship with her daughter
and sadly that tragedy and the fate of
helena ravenclaw
is what we'll remember most about rowena
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live
[Music]